former stylist for TV host and producer
Ryan Secrets is publicly detailing
sexual harassment allegations against
him for the first time in an interview
with Variety Suzy Hardy described
numerous incidents of harassment and
assault allegedly perpetrated by Ryan
Seacrest from 2007 to 2013
Jericka Duncan is here with why Hardy is
going public now Tirico good morning
good morning the stylist attorney
notified the e television network of the
alleged misconduct back in November it
was Seacrest himself who then took the
allegations public without naming Hardy
he denied the claims hardy says the
results of an investigation forced her
to come forward now Ryan Seacrest is one
of America's most recognizable TV
personalities but it's his alleged
actions off-camera that are now putting
him in the spotlight in an interview
with variety Seacrest former stylist
Suzi Hardy says she suffered years of
unwanted sexual aggression by Seacrest
saying he grinded against her while
wearing only his underwear groped her
genitals and slapped her buttock slapped
her so hard that it left a welt that was
still visible hours later when she got
home variety's senior TV reporter Daniel
Holloway spoke to Hardy photograph that
welt shared a with investigators we've
seen that photograph a variety as well
in 2013 Hardy says Human Resources for
II asked her about her relationship with
Seacrest and she says she was fired
after she told them what happened but
this past November saying she was
emboldened by the me2 movement Hardy had
her lawyer send a letter to E detailing
her allegations the company hired
outside counsel to conduct an internal
investigation which found insufficient
evidence to substantiate allegations
against Seacrest hardy told variety ease
investigation left her with a feeling of
total exasperation saying it was obvious
the investigator was whitewashing it for
Seacrest side we know that the
investigator did not reach out to four
people that she referred to him
who she said could help corroborate her
story he responded Monday by saying its
investigation was extremely
comprehensive and thorough any claims
that questioned the legitimacy of this
investigation are completely baseless
Seacrest's attorney says it is upsetting
to us that variety is electing to run a
story about untrue allegations he added
that Hardy threatened to make false
claims unless she was paid 15 million
dollars a charge Hardy and her lawyer
told variety was untrue we obviously
wouldn't have published this story if we
didn't feel that it was highly credible
and highly compelling Hardy's lawyer did
not respond to our request for comment
Seacrest is still scheduled to appear on
live with Kelly and Ryan this week tape
American Idol this weekend and hosts
ease red carpet for the Oscars on Sunday
and the reboot of the new American Idol
starts in a couple of weeks too so
there's more to come I'm sure on this
story this isn't last we've heard of it
and Jericka just the the e investigation
that was done by an outside law firm
that was done we believe by an outside
law firm they interviewed multiple
people this woman says she was
interviewed at least three times but
again claims that she felt as though
those investigators really were on the
side of Ryan Seacrest got it okay thank
you thanks to you